the chickens
[Music]
clear out and nothing
my name is rosa flores I am 16 years old
I am a singer and I am trying to
preserve the Quechua language Quechua
is a language of our ancestors the
Incas and also in our culture
and this language is now  is losing
in Peru people see it in Quechua
as a symbol of poverty or
discrimination
if Quechua is lost it would also be
likely to disappear from Peru
I have already started singing modern songs
in Quechua mostly so that young people
can listen to it so they can like it and
learn the  quechua means
that the songs shown in quechua
were michael jackson's he says it
's
[Music]
michael jackson's song is very
difficult it had more than a million visits
and it was
believing
knowing changes in the way of thinking in
this language of  part of the young people
I would like to teach people and
continue with our design project
[Applause]
[Music]